[Music]
welcome back to off the record we talk
about
whatever you want what are we saying
about dj khaled what does he do
he's a producer right yeah he makes
beats but why does he perform
we the best music rapping he just says
stuff in the background he's
inspirational as well it's like branding
your uh your beats like they've been
doing that
oh man since the beginning how does he
perform
that's what i mean i don't have a
problem with him like branding himself
on songs i get it it's his beats
his artist whatever you hear like you
said you saw him at the uh
yeah he was performing at that um
trailer fight
with or maybe not the trailer one the
tick tocker youtuber fight
and a clip went viral because he was out
there performing a song
and the audience wasn't singing along
with him but it's always other people on
his song though yeah it's weird because
it's the hype man being the performer
usually the hype man is with
a rapper or a singer a performer someone
else is kind of the star of the show and
the hype man's just there
to add some flavor yeah he is also the
star
and so everyone's like oh what the [ __ ]
is happening but i think i think he
became famous for two reasons right like
one is like when
our era knew him for the music and then
two it was snapchat yeah when he started
[ __ ] around
and then that he became a meme it's a
rock so i think he became he kind of
reinvented
became a meme like a comedian a
personality
my whole thing is like when he performs
what is he saying yeah what does he do i
can't i can't recall a verse i can only
hear his lines
he doesn't rap at all he has zero verses
on his songs yeah when he uh when he he
did um
he did rihanna's what that uh i forget
what it's called but it was on amazon
prime or whatever right she did like two
fashion shows
right and then the second oh her savage
fun teeth savage fancy there it is and
he did a performance
uh and he comes out but he's like with
big sean he's with like all these other
rappers and they're doing everything and
he just like walks by them he's like in
like a white pimp suit you know he's
walks by and he's just like
another one yeah i get that yeah and
that's like the whole performance all he
needs to do
so i can't imagine him being by himself
because like that's like an acapella
that's like
instrumental yeah what's he doing dj's
do though it's not like what does steve
aoki do man he's just mixing [ __ ] he
doesn't even say anything
he's just playing other people's music
but at least he's mixing you know what i
mean
he's up there doing something he throws
cake yeah do you have any dj experience
because i never know what what are they
twisting and turning and [ __ ]
what it used to be [ __ ]
it was like no it's like and they're
like i don't hear
anything i mean i i produced that dj'd
but yeah he doesn't know any
uh he didn't know any kid what are what
are all those [ __ ] knobs everyone's
turning knocks
nowadays it's like you'll have like a
mixer or a sound board and it does all
the work for you
you'll see you'll set certain things so
that they control different things it's
not
say like this particular button does
this thing it's like you said it in the
software
so it's like this button will be like my
snares this button will be like my extra
kick or my drum
this one will be random like a hype
vocal that's like yeah
and then you'll just like set those
things so so you can either press the
mpc to like control the sounds or the
knobs will like you'll also set the
knobs to be something whether it be
a leveler or uh something that gives
distortion or something that adds like
just a
speed ramp on snares right before like
the one like you'll just [ __ ]
yeah now when i worked in a high rise
and i pretended like i was working
like when people because they always do
headphones on headphones off headphones
on
headphones off turn night turn turn out
turn knob training you see them go like
nah that's not it
and then they go like this and like and
they're like
what changed the boss is watching me the
boss is watching me
because back in the day it was it was
mixing back in the day
you know you basically had the
crossfader which will you have two
turntables that's the only button i
understand what about the other one
so back in the day it was crossfader and
then you had levels
volume control right and then you had a
mixer where you could equalize
and and change that because you know you
don't want all the sounds to mesh like
if the lows or whatever whatever so you
have to kind of blend it
so that was the og dj and you just kept
the music
going without any stops right and you
might for example like on track one
maybe they got like a certain beat and
then on track two which has the same bpm
maybe to fade it in you take out the
lows or all the basses so you just bring
in the snare or the melody
into the first song and then so you
start hearing the melody of the track
but you're not getting distorted by like
the bases and then as you fade out the
lows on this one
using the base from this yeah and in the
kick or whatever but then
that's just blending right but now
mixing
is all automated like the beat matching
all that [ __ ]
the the skill is basically taken out of
that like back in the day where you're
they're
listening because they're beat matching
trying to match the record at the same
bpm
but now the computer does it for you so
then the computer
is already getting like matching the
snare or whatever it needs to
and now you could do presets like like
they're just ghost twisting
they're [ __ ] no no they're they're
adding they're remixing
so you're doing live remixes you might
even get an acapella from something else
and then put that on you could
layer multiple tracks it's more than
just two turntables now you could have
like
[ __ ] 30 different waves but you can
realistically
do your entire set like pre-mix it yeah
so you're
in essence just pressing true for the
performance true but then like
just adding extra random things during
even though the mix is already done
because you know when you see like a
saxophone player right like
every button or every physical movement
is matched with
what i'm hearing yeah i see that right
this was [ __ ] going like this and you
hear no difference nothing
nothing yeah but are you feeling his
energy
you want to see him do work though i
want to see someone [ __ ] come and
handcuff his ass
if i feel any different maybe
maybe that's the thing you have to be on
some directions
you got to be rolling part of the show
though different frequencies you want to
see
you want to see a guy up there working
you don't want to see him stand up there
and just stand up there yeah maybe
you're on acid and then suddenly when
you like see him doing this there's like
frequencies that you never knew were
even there
you know what i mean like going into
people's ears or you're going to drop
more eat have you seen how people
do like one man band [ __ ] though it's
like yeah they'll they'll record a
segment
so that's also doable like a drum loop
right yeah so like you're playing a song
and then you make like a
you make a mix yeah and it's almost like
live
like mastering a song or mixing as it's
going to
and then you can do like live
progressions but also you can have midi
controllers
midi controllers are just like having a
keyboard and then
you can add whatever sounds you want and
then play live so i like the banjo guys
with the [ __ ] harmonica in their face
that also have like the [ __ ] like
drum kicks now those guys are working
hard you can tell
and you got the [ __ ] bass drum in the
back that hits when you hit the [ __ ]
yeah i give
mad respect to one man bands like when
you see them live perform and like
it's [ __ ] cool actually yeah you
gotta tip them like they're a five-man
band dude
this is for your mouth this is for your
hand
it's for your butt with the drum have
you seen little tokyo uh
arthur that who's been one man banding
since i was
born dude he's always singing cover
songs and [ __ ] now it's pretty sad
though because he's always rolling up in
a wheelchair
and like he's doing his thing he's
falling apart yeah but i remember being
like 17
fishing at santa monica pier and that's
what would just like be our background
music all night
yeah but now he's like got two teeth and
he's still going on man
and he's just lonely as [ __ ] yeah he's
always doing pretty woman
i was always worried about the remember
you remember you ever been to venice and
you see the cat with um
the guitar on the roller skates yeah but
during covet i was like wait what's he
gonna do
yeah cuz like nobody's out right now
some of those guys are still there
have you seen the bird [ __ ] uh piano man
there's a
there's a piano guy on at venice cove
with
bird [ __ ] cause his birds land on his
piano just [ __ ] all over it yeah that
[ __ ] with the piano maybe it gives it
its character
sound that sounds all different how big
is the piano
it's just right and then he pushes it
it's on rollers and he pushes it into
yeah where does he keep it i have no
idea dude but it's covered in bird [ __ ]
no they're cleaning up venice right now
are they yeah there's uh they're trying
to get rid of
everybody who is living on the beach so
everyone so
the unhoused is what they call unhoused
i don't know what
they're sending them to vegas dude
summerlin area you know that's right
yeah they're cleaning
us and everything it's pretty crazy
because i ride bikes there
and i don't know if you guys been during
the pandemic i've seen because there's
always been
homeless i've seen videos and it looks
crazy but it's another level
from the beginning of venice all the way
to santa monica the whole
like it's just rows and rows and rows i
just saw this article come out where it
was like i think la spent six billion
dollars or something on the homeless
situation and the population went from
30k to 80k
so they spent money in a group and it
grew somehow it's like in san francisco
they're spending like
30 000 for tents or some [ __ ] yeah like
people are again i think homeless people
are being posted up in tents in a
parking lot and getting paid like 2 100
bucks a month
what the [ __ ] yeah in san fran yeah wow
holy [ __ ] that's cool just print more
money and solve this guys that's working
i know right slowly today's video is
brought to you by
feels feels isn't about what you feel
okay
you don't get high on this stuff it's
about what you do not feel
and that is stress anxiety
too much excitement to the point where
you're like i need to calm down
and before we went hiking i went with my
good old friend
david and david is super afraid of
heights
and we decided to take a little bit of
cbd before we went on this
and i didn't know how bad uh
this hike was gonna be until we got
there
and i said to myself this guy will not
be able to handle this
you know how scared of heights he is so
you know our new vegas house
he got upstairs you know you on one you
could see both sides you started
crawling on the floor
on the balcony no on the inside of the
house
inside of the house i don't want to look
downstairs
good for us we had some fields we
dropped a couple of
on our tongue we went and we said all
right
let's get on the road and then we
decided to go further into this hike
and then he was like oh my god this is
crazy but he completed it and he said
that
i swear to god if i didn't have cbd i
don't think i would have been able to
complete this
and it helped chill them out that's
tight what i also like about fields is
they actually have a customer hotline
for people that are new to cbd
and you can call them because it's one
of those things where you do want to
experiment with the dose to see what
works good for you
and that way you have the support of the
actual company so if you want to check
it out go to feels.com that's f e
a l s dot com slash off the record to
get 50
off your first order plus free shipping
that's fuels.com
off the record to get 50 off your first
order plus free shipping
i do have to say that i drove by skid
row the other day and it was the
emptiest i've ever seen it maybe they
all went to venice but they're
i was like pretty shocked well if you're
gonna be anywhere there's gonna be
events beach
kicked out a bunch of people out of the
arts district they had like a bunch of
encampments and and
or just like tents that like i remember
when they were it was like 110 and
you're like oh snap look there's like a
tent here now and then it turned into
like six or seven tenths and then cover
the whole street on like second street
now they're all gone yesterday i was
just like oh [ __ ] they're gone
and then you start seeing rvs pull up
too like just old rvs number six
yeah they're like the whole colonies and
[ __ ] because these rvs look like they're
made in the 60s
and i'm like how did they even run like
did they get a tow truck to pull the rv
and park it there
like some of these guys are living large
man yeah some winnebago [ __ ] for sure
we should do like a like an mtv cribs
like vlog
and just see if we can find like the
most pimped out homeless shelter i've
seen one where
this lady had like a house in a garage
and her inside of her house my garage
yeah it actually looked pretty cool i
bet you someone was living better than
like
some of us dude the tiny houses are
legit yeah some of those are
crazy looking inside did you see the
pasadena one you're costing by
he has his own little corner to himself
he has a [ __ ] dish
uh satellite dish yeah off the freeway
yeah and then he has like a tent
but he has a garden and everything is
like it actually looks really pretty and
i'm like
no wonder you're a pasadena homeless wow
south pass and still there that's pretty
good right yeah if the neighbors don't
care that's big
it's right on the border between like
pasadena and l.a because that's the only
place you can
really get away with it right like right
at the border because in burbank i know
anytime
there's a homeless person or a tent that
gets set up
police officers come pick them up and
drop them in like glendale or some [ __ ]
la or whatever right out of the burbank
i was in irvine homeless people get
picked up and dropped off in santa ana
and then i was like
santa as well i was born i get it how
would you like to how would you like to
live where they drop off the homeless
people you're like wait a minute
you know the city of honolulu they sued
like detroit and all these other cities
because they found out that
a lot of the homeless people there were
being
sent by these other cities with one-way
tickets
they would they would you know have
homeless people at the shelters clean
them up
um give them a one-way ticket to hawaii
and then
they they basically become homeless
again that's the best thing about when
they do the rnc and the dnc the
conventions
yeah they always just take all the
homeless people and just ship them out
to somewhere else just to get them away
from the city so it looks okay for a
couple days
and then they'll come back they'll come
back of course that's crazy man
that just blows my mind how this [ __ ]
like happens and we're supposed to be
like this richest country in the world
yeah and then you drive around and
you're like man sometimes i feel like
we're not that rich well we're not but
there's some people who are really rich
it's like oh wow
all you gotta do is go to one really
rich town and like that's that richness
makes up for like you know
geographically like half the state yeah
that's true it's almost like you can
live
blindly and and and it's almost like
there's this bubble
right where you don't see the real
america and then you're just kind of
like man life is great here what are you
talking about
it's it's awesome that's like corona del
mar nobody cares about homelessness
unless it's in their neighborhood
especially if you live in a bubble where
you don't see it like say like very rich
parts of
like san marino very rich area exactly
same because we were just talking about
south pass by the freeway right
like if those [ __ ] homeless people
are like 500 yards over and in san
marino that would never happen
but maybe that's where they're getting
all their supplies though like the san
marino
garbage yeah people leave their stuff
outside they come out they grab it bring
it back to their place yo
because they they they leave out some
good [ __ ] my desk at my house
was from some house san reno someone
left it out there we're gonna go pick it
up because my neighbors
they were um what do you call them those
cat uh those those trash treasure
diggers
dumpster divers dumpster divers yeah
yeah like that's a politically correct
term
is it i don't know because i had a big
wheel that
showed up one day at their house and i
was like i used to have the same one
come to find out it was mine that my dad
threw away because it broke
they fixed it and they kept it but i
used to go dumpster diving with them
because i thought it was a fun
family thing to do like when you're in
elementary school right like in second
third grade
you go you just think it's a thing you
do right like like if you have a yard
sale or whatever
we're really learning about joe's
history today is just like joseph you're
telling me
at okay in like if you're in second
grade or like third grade dad didn't
take you to the dump
and and if if if a family is doing this
thing
would you question it or would you be
like oh yeah that's normal everyone does
it well i mean it sounds like you
pitched it like we're supposed to have
all
done that too but we're all just going
like what yeah well my neighbors did
that right and then so
um like it'll be like like i sleep over
whatever and they're like early in the
morning
before the trash man comes we would just
go and
look for [ __ ] and then sometimes they'll
drive to
like a nice neighborhood like palos
verdes or whatever and then like just
try to look around they always had the
dope stuff they'll put it on the curb
yeah they'll put on the curb
that's the best stuff yeah low-key like
they're not digging in the trash
like that's all the diapers and garbage
is well that's why it's
dumpster yeah that sounds like like
that's like
it's a dumpster but usually on trash day
they'll leave like bookshelves
beds whatever out there because they
know people will pick it up half the
stuff in my house that's different
there's dumpster driving there's
sidewalk surfing side sidewalk surfing
yeah that's like a scavenger hunt
that's fun yeah you might i'm a sidewalk
surfer bro yeah me and my wife sidewalk
surfers
and we r she bro she does all types of
like vin she gets because vintage is
like the hot thing right yeah she's like
super into that [ __ ]
so it's what people do is like at the
farmer's market or whatever flea markets
they'll get this stuff they'll repaint
it yeah and they'll sell it for
like way over price three times the
price or something but we do it we
bring it to our house and half the [ __ ]
in our house like our coffee table
or [ __ ] that's what my girl's been
doing with uh like offer up and facebook
marketplace by the way
clutch bro picking up [ __ ] and there's
there'd be times where i'm like why the
[ __ ] do you pick that up she's like
because i'm gonna resell it
and i'm like what i love you but where
did she find it
it's just like offer up her facebook how
did they how do they know the uh
like how does she know that she can
resell it that's just like couponing
she'll like look it up
right and then she'll see like msrp on
some other places and then she'll like
check the other market areas like the
public marketplaces
and she's like oh i can totally sell
this for an upcharge so she'll buy like
a patio set for like
200 bucks i'm like why the [ __ ] do we
need a patty so we don't have big enough
patio she's like because i could sell
for 350.
she did wow do it again that's true
there's this guy that he made like a
million dollar business on amazon
by buying clearance aisle from like uh
target and stuff because you'll look at
the price and be like oh [ __ ] this is on
for five bucks i could sell it for 10
and then you'll buy all the clearance
items and then sell it on amazon because
people want to get rid of [ __ ]
so you could take it and resell it and
there it is sidewalk surfers dude my
mother-in-law came home one day
to my house and she goes oh we have a
brand new couch for you guys
we got a brand new couch and it's
completely randy she found it on the
sidewalk
in a rich area it was completely brand
new it was in a box bro it was in a box
i want to see all the mishmash furniture
in your house
surprisingly i don't design none of this
stuff my wife is very good at it
and our house looks very nice well you
said couch in a box i don't know couch
just came in a box couch in a box but it
was a fold-out couch
it's crazy a futon yeah okay outside
i'm looking at a couch like i'm gonna
i'm gonna take a picture of this for you
guys and then
i'll show you i'm like is it a bluff
couch in a box
yeah unless it has a bet is it a bed
couch thing it can go flat
it's from ikea that's a [ __ ] futon
it's a beanbag chair tony it's a whole
mattress it come in a box
you just blow it up piece of cake and
then you bend it over so it sits right
that's
it and it's a chair too yeah
take some of the air out it's strong
enough it could be a blanket too
the blanket idea i like i like dude
nick's house is gonna be crazy
that's crazy dude when i was moving you
know how i had to move in like three
days
remember that you helped me move and
[ __ ] joe was like hey come help me move
and i was like okay
i went there he's like take all this
[ __ ] and i was like cool
i gave out thousands of dollars worth of
[ __ ] because i couldn't find a way to
get rid of it
but there's probably my walk surfing
skills are really really impressive but
there's probably like a bunch of people
like me that just needs to get
rid of [ __ ] as soon as possible that's
exactly what it is yeah i have to [ __ ]
on the marketplace where you get some
really good deals
is because they're like i'm moving just
come take it just take it
honestly no [ __ ] i'm moving this
weekend if you want some free [ __ ]
okay yeah i'm picking up my keys tonight
how come you
you're giving away stuff you don't need
some of it every time you move it's like
it's either you're taking you kind of
like go through your own spring cleaning
right you're just like did i even
[ __ ] use this here at
all recondol yourself dude you just got
your new setup and you're moving already
i got okay well it's long story short i
i ended up moving spot because like uh
in the pandemic right um all the uh
rent prices dropped dramatically in arts
district but the thing is because i had
a lease already they were raising my
brand so i was staying at a building
called the gary and artistry
and my my lease was going up to four
thousand what when the same
the same building was off i literally
searched the [ __ ] website they were
offering the same apartment used for 3
100 during the time wow
and so we made a complaint as well and
we were just like yo like can we just
get this new price like no because
you're already in the lease
so we just like moving out to the next
building but then i only put in an eight
month lease because i didn't know where
things were going to go with the
pandemic
and then we ended up having to close our
artistic studio anyway so now
i was like all right cool i'll move out
so the place we're moving to is saving
more money
i'm technically spending like this much
more but i'm getting like 600 more
square feet
oh wow yeah so it's like really really
different that's huge in l.a
that's a whole new apartment that's why
i'm moving to glendale though
you know yeah that's where the homeless
people get dropped out are you moving
yourself uh it's me and
my fiancee just the two of you guys just
two of us i hate moving dude i hate it i
know i do too which is why i'm telling
nick to come over and get some free
stuff in my life i like helping people
move
but if anyone needs to move ask nick
yeah i'll help you move i'm not gonna
take your stuff
i like helping my friends move you
really yeah i [ __ ] hate moving dude
yeah i
hate moving myself i'm genuinely going
to hit you up because i don't like
moving
me up dude i like i like trying to move
stuff and fitting it in the face are you
down to move
your head yeah yeah are you down to move
if the
owner's not even there
can you help me move please i'll see you
tomorrow
not that dumb
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you